[Music]
in sorcery scam news submitted by a man
was sent to prison for engaging in a
witchcraft extortion scheme what do they
do they extorted the witch no that'd be
awesome
the witch exhorted the man with the
spell yeah she's like if you do this I
will cast a spell on you unless you pay
me a little bit okay so this was an
argentine mastermind is what they're
calling him of an international
witchcraft extortion scheme whoo they
targeted hundreds of people and so they
were looking for love and so they we all
yeah I found it so I got lucky we're the
lucky ones we're gonna make it baby now
a lot of people get to look for love and
get it this man his name is Ariel he's
31 years old he offered to help people
find their one true love soulmate by
using magic spells and he advertised the
services on Facebook and Instagram and
so when people would contact his company
they were told to record themselves
performing sexually explicit rituals
then he would threaten to post those
videos on social media unless they paid
him large sums of money that's the easy
way to get oh my god this [ __ ]
is dumb because they make it could have
made money two ways already legally yeah
what's the second one so the first way
is there already trusting them so
they're gonna do this jackoff spell
right they do the they do the
masturbation spell and then they pay
money and then they believe in this [ __ ]
and then you could post there's their
videos on a voyeuristic porn site
monetize it monetize that's the second
one instead of treating a situation do
you make money on that [ __ ] I never
tried using the pornhub oh yeah really
and then charge them to take it off you
have a huge video [ __ ] oh my god that's
smart you owe three weeks and then an
upfront fee is four ways there's oh five
then because then you can
how to do the jackoff session and then
you can have like maybe three four
sessions that they have to pay for after
that and then the extortion begins and
then open up a porn tree on and then
have a compilation but nobody cares
about seeing guys jackoff something do
you want to see you guys check off I
mean there's a lot of girl what about
gay sites oh you know not true but girls
like that girls different girls feel for
different deal I would love to watch
Bart jackoff out I know Bart jackoff
yeah I'm talking about it's Randall eyes
like random dudes ran deuces [ __ ]
free ball jerking it no you don't want
to see so that's alone jacking off no
see you know rocky one rocky one salon
[ __ ] Jason Momoa oh yeah everyone see
but not not any [ __ ] dude
yeah what if those are like a look-alike
then good-looking and I don't have to
see or not good-looking but I have to
see their face but they're good-looking
what's the big good-looking you know
like the body like you know like fit if
they need to use witchcraft define love
they're probably ugly as hell are
they're [ __ ] or there might be
lonely old ladies yes so then this guy
he they're saying that he targeted
roughly 200 people in countries
including the US Switzerland Mexico and
Spain and then there are three other
people our or bilingual trilingual
quadrant angles cuz they target it all
over the world so they're easy either
using Google Translate or they know how
to speak a lot of language or maybe
everyone's just speaking English well
they're just true there's give Babel
fishing the whole thing probably pacing
well he's from Argentina so espanol they
arrested three other people including
his 15 year 15 year old brother so did
they get Interpol on this because they
that's an international crime you know
to me that's like mmhmm yeah there was a
lot of people working together they said
that in one case they he demanded 250
thousand dollars from a quote
well-connected public figure with access
to significant financial resources
yeah 250,000 yeah like people that had
[ __ ] to lose
what if I was bath pouch it was at least
12 countries that he targeted victims
what if there was Kim Carter
no it wouldn't be Kim Kardashian I sure
would have been like [ __ ] it yeah yeah
she's like everyone's seen it already
yeah and she found love with Connie yes
it was mainly it seems like mainly
spanish-speaking countries of us but
away Argentina why Libya Chile the
Dominican Republic what the mullah Italy
Mexico Peru Spain and Switzerland well
that's a mainly Spanish mainly yeah
because neither does Switzerland yeah
she'd be like yeah right you're not
opposed to [ __ ] she's like go ahead go
ahead my revive my career walk ahead
she's at Doug so the way they caught him
was because one of these agents they
they wire transfer like Western Union
transferred over the money to him and so
he went to go pick it up and out of
white and that's where authorities were
waiting for him that's our waiting oh my
god that's scary go how do you say it
green going Paraguay Paraguay pear where
is that him right there
this is him Interpol
they got and Interpol did get up I
thought that was like a witch because
this is all about sorcery and stuff Oh
that'd be tight she's got is he wearing
like a bulletproof vest or that same guy
I'm confused too soon this will go back
I mean worth it I don't know what that
is that's him that's there's like a
different dude he looks weird
his body is [ __ ] sure can you make
sense of this [ __ ] his hands look
swollen he looks like a marshmallow
he's a Michelin Man he is a Michelin Man
he needs witchcraft
advertising has worked on you very well
a Michelin's proud of themselves today
they love that like anytime somebody
sees a fat dude who looks weirdly shaped
Weather Watch
ya know I love it we're like the
Michelin men or the marshmallow man
who's a marshmallow burrito sober
Doughboy or which one's the one that I
got really blown up and honey I blew up
the kid the kid the baby dude the baby
did know hey forget it
anyway oh no that was ghostbusters that
was ghostbusters yeah the Martian to
stay [ __ ] Marc Bolan yeah that was
wasn't that Ghostbusters the marshmallow
man ahead Rick Moranis in it too so I
get the crossover oh I don't know Steve
Martin damn it mom
every white dad Steve Martin yep so yeah
they kind of oh oh so that was the end
they all [ __ ] that's crazy I was waiting
for you to tell the story sucker start
talking
what story I've been through you oh man
then you can start telling the story
time you know what I when I first heard
of this wizard scam I was I was hoping I
was just waiting for the moment that you
would talk about this real like
witchcraft underground won't use that to
lure people is that all somebody asked
for it
this spell was like the introduction I
want to see his ad like how do you
promote Harry Potter's online shitty
After Effects graphic saying that the
love ritual began with candles alcohol
vegetables and photographs all carefully
arranged the first step is [ __ ]
blessing this cantaloupe and then
[ __ ] it mm-hmm
if you're a lady the first step is to
bless this cucumber with holy water and
then you [ __ ] it
then you shove it up your [ __ ] and
then you shove it in your mouth and then
good and then he's like hey he's like
look at the video that's really
incriminating isn't it and then you're
like yeah I guess I'll pay up [ __ ]
should that [ __ ] suck it out of my
ass
there was this one page right these
people did
it's cuz they're they're so desperate
for love that's how bad these people are
they want love so bad that they would
[ __ ] [ __ ] a carrot or advocare [ __ ]
it and thinking that it was like
witchcraft like they were still that
association with it and they encode it
yeah and then they would have like this
magic spell yeah they sync audio and
encode that [ __ ] they wait for it and
then he's like hey is it ready like ants
is 30 minutes in stone color that's
pretty sad dude he's like hey it says
it's not mp4 and like oh sorry I sent it
again I'm on a Mac I didn't order do it
so if this guy didn't do it for money
but he did it for trolls I'd be okay
with it okay I see that I can see that
you know why it doesn't feel like well
you just use kind of humiliating them
but then in a different way I guess it's
okay no I'm it's about intent for you
I'm against it you know why because at
the end of the day he's taking advantage
of people who just want something nice
like like love right yeah there's this
other site because it reminded me of
this guy that used to oust Instagram
models that kind of talked down on
people and then they're like I'm living
this life of like luxury and then yes
but they would they would basically
figure out that they're all high class
hookers yes and then he would convince
them to basically like do very
humiliating humiliating things like poop
in the bathroom floor and all that and
then record it and then yeah so you have
like it's so funny because you have
these like like Instagram models right
that's in professional pictures and have
the most expensive designer bags they're
like you know it takes a lot to be an
entrepreneur and they have like these
motivational quotes and [ __ ] and then I
have this image of them pooping figuring
[ __ ] on the tile floor yeah taking a
squatting and taking a Dookie on the
towel floor and then yeah exactly yeah
and some of these we've all like the
business like transactions that they do
they do some crazy [ __ ] they'll be like
so the guy would pretend to be like some
very rich Saudi prince or something and
he'll be like I have a camel will you do
nasty things to my camera
and I don't like sure now they'll be
like I have nephew he is underage he
wants to have woman first type will you
do it and then she's like yeah [ __ ] yeah
so there's crazy so getting [ __ ] good on
them it's like the lease and then
sometimes I'm like you know what they
deserve all the air flutter for airfare
everything that they get I deserve all
of that [ __ ] the [ __ ] that they have to
do Oh
anyone that's willing to suck a camel
off they work hard for their money but
then the facade I think the worst thing
is that there's a lot of young girls
what like seeing Instagram seeing these
girls travel the world they look up to
them and they think like oh this is
awesome you know I'm gonna sell my
sexuality and do the same [ __ ] but it's
it's all a facade a lot I don't know
they're camel [ __ ] yes they're
sucking camel dick you think sucking on
a camel is like same thing as eating a
Kiwi I know it is it might be
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]